what up people
i'm dave rubin this is the reuben report
direct message
for march 24th 2021 as always
click that subscribe button and tap that
notification bell so that you see our
videos
in your feed and i should note before we
begin today
i was going to mail it in today i've got
a lot going on as i've been saying
there's been a lot of local stuff
happening big announcements next week i
was just gonna
phone it in i was gonna act like a
regular youtube host and just phone it
in
but then i realized as i walked into the
studio it's my director
connor's birthday today and i thought i
can't
i can't phone it in for connor so i'm
going to bring it today
that's right people an absolutely laser
focused episode of the reuben report
a little bit of information a little bit
of sarcasm
a little bit of humor and a little bit
of hope that's what i'm going to bring
you
today on the rubid report direct message
we got four stories for you first off
you're not going to believe this
i am going to at least partially
give bernie sanders credit for something
that's right so
make sure that you're you know solid in
your chair i don't want you falling out
of your chair
make sure when i do this story in just a
moment that you're not drinking anything
i don't want you to do a spit take ruin
your computer or your laptop or your
ipad or whatever it might be
so that's a very important point there
then you're not going to believe this
but more democratic politicians are
racist
yeah that's right they're very very
racist people they call everyone else
racists
but they're the racists we're gonna get
to that uh then i thought this was
really interesting project veritas which
is james
o'keefe's uh operation i've had james
o'keefe on the show i think he's a good
guy
uh they are suing the new york times
uh over some of their reporting not only
over some of their reporting but
basically the way the new york times
reported
on project veritas's reporting so i
thought that was pretty interesting
uh and then you know because we've done
so much about how the states are so
wildly doing
different covid measures i thought we'd
do actually
a direct comparison between my home
state
well my home state's technically new
york but my
the current state that i live in of
california versus the place that i dream
of
you know it's florida and we're going to
actually compare the numbers and dive
into all of that so it's a jam pack show
and as i said
laser focused people i'm ready to go
before we do anything else though
i want to talk to you about hartford
gold you know i spend a lot of time
talking about cancel culture and how the
left
tries to silence people and issues they
don't want to hear about
here's something we can't cancel though
no matter how much or no matter how hard
we close our eyes
or plug our ears the biden
administration is spending excessively
while killing energy jobs and dragging
out lockdowns
this can be catastrophic for the
american dollar which is why it is smart
to invest in things that are real
with intrinsic value which is why i'm
encouraging you guys to invest in gold
i recommend you speak to my friends at
american hartford gold they sell
physical gold and silver delivered right
to your door
or inside your ira plus they make it
easy with an a
plus rating from the better business
bureau and thousands of satisfied
clients i know you will come to trust
them too
when you call today they will give you
up to fifteen hundred dollars of free
silver with your first order
so now is a great time to check them out
call
nine three 866-219-9311 one that's eight
six six two one nine
nine three one one or text reuben to six
five five three two don't wait secure
your financial future with gold and now
back to me
all right people this is gonna be a
tough one to swallow but i'm gonna do it
bernie sanders kinda got something right
just in the last few days
and i'm gonna get to it in a moment but
sure he got it wrong before that and
he's gonna kind of get it wrong going
forward
but i'm gonna do the best i can as an
impartial arbiter of the truth
here at the reuben report to give bernie
sanders a little bit of credit so bernie
sanders
uh did an interview with ezra klein
uh in the new york times now ezra klein
is either the
ceo or ceo can we get what he is of vox
he's basically in charge of ox
i don't particularly like or respect as
recline he's gone after me a couple
times
you know he's he's sort of in the woke
world and vox is just
absolute trash but in any event bernie
sanders was interviewed by
ezra he's the editor at large thank you
and the founder
of vox we get information on the fly
here at the reuben report
uh but bernie was interviewed by mr ezra
klein
in the new york times and he said this
and i'm going to give
credit where it's due he said look
should i do this in bernie boyce
look you have a racist sexist xenophobe
pathological liar an authoritarian
a bad news guy sanders said but if
you're asking me do i feel particularly
comfortable
that the president of the united states
could not express his views on twitter
i don't feel comfortable about that
social media shouldn't serve as a
platform for authoritarian purposes and
insurrection
and if anybody who thinks yesterday it
was donald trump who was banned tomorrow
it could be somebody else who has a very
different point of view
all right so you get it so just in the
last few days
bernie sanders is basically saying that
big tech shouldn't have the power
to de-person people that big tech
shouldn't have the power
to just mass ban people and as you all
know after the
events of uh the capital on january 6
big tech performed a digital
assassination of donald trump they took
them off twitter and youtube and
facebook and instagram
and pinterest and spotify and everywhere
else and now two months later bernie
sanders is actually kind of getting it
right
it's a little odd because you know
bernie sanders all his policies are very
authoritarian right
his policies are always giving more
power to the government to do
whatever the government wants now he
thinks it'll do apparently only good
things if he's in charge
but what i always say is you want a
government with so little power it can't
do that much good and it can't do that
much bad that's the trade-off that you
get in a free society
but that being said i'm glad that bernie
sort of
gets uh you know a little something
let's say
about free speech he kind of gets it
this is
worrisome that the government or that
private companies
could basically take out the most
powerful person in the world the reason
i said the government there well let's
get to a
a tweet from a bernie sanders that
you'll recognize a bit more
this is from january 11 2021 so this is
you know five days after the capitol
hill event and this is when they
did that digital assassination of donald
trump
let's be clear if trump is too dangerous
to send out a tweet
or a facebook post he's too dangerous to
be commander in chief
donald trump must be removed from office
immediately
and held accountable for his horrific
acts of sedition
violence and chaos ah there's the bernie
we know and love
the bernie who doesn't get it at all
okay bernie so five days after this
whole thing happened
in effect bernie was saying that if
someone is booted
off twitter and facebook that that's
enough for the government
to actually take them out too right
that's enough
to basically say okay trump should be
impeached now or otherwise just removed
from office
for those last two weeks of his
presidency which absolutely nothing
happened and then the democrats ran
a sham impeachment thing but the reason
i said government before
as i was starting to say private company
is there's something uh very interesting
about what bernie's tweet is really
saying there can we put the tweet up one
more time because it's the first part
of the tweet that's interesting and i'll
do it in bernie voice just the first
part again
let's be clear if trump is too dangerous
to send out a tweet
or a facebook post he's too dangerous to
be commander-in-chief
okay so think about what he's saying
there he's saying that
if the tech oligarchs decide
that someone is too dangerous and by
dangerous what he means is they just
disagree with the tech oligarchs then
they're too dangerous to be
commander-in-chief
isn't that outsourcing of tyranny right
our founders were afraid of tyranny from
the government because they could have
never imagined that we would have these
companies that would be
a superstructure far more powerful than
the government in many ways right i mean
think about your own life
which has more power and engagement in
your day-to-day operations the
government
or the device that you're holding that
has all of your information and all of
your communications and everything else
like there is this thing now
this this sort of unwieldly endless
monster that we can't even
grasp how powerful it is that we just
keep giving power over to
so bernie's actually saying something
very dangerous there that
if those guys who are completely
unaccountable for everything if big
tech decides this guy's too dangerous
well then certainly he's too dangerous
to be president and of course that then
added fuel to the fire of getting rid of
trump and the second impeachment which
was
a total sham and waste of time and
everything else so
i will give bernie credit for kind of
making some sense
a few days ago at the same time i will
mock him
you know for not properly understanding
the issues when it mattered
um you know two months ago but i will
add this if
you're watching bernie if you're
watching well then how about not just
saying
the right thing now you're kind of
getting it now that of course it's not
going to
stop with donald trump right and perhaps
some of us two years ago should have
offered a better defense of alex jones
regardless of what you think about
alex jones and by the way i had a mea
culpa on this about two years ago i said
i should have offered a better defense
because it wasn't going to stop with
alex jones that's not a commentary on
anything alex jones has said or done it
really is not
but of course it wasn't going to stop
with him and then it gets to trump
and then of course they'll come for
other people so i'm glad you got that
now bernie
but you want to do something real bernie
you want to do something you want to
actually do something besides talk which
i know is the fear
of every progressive right progressives
are good at talking and burning things
down but not really building things
well all right bernie how about you lead
a campaign to get donald trump back on
big tech
how about you don't just say oh two
months after i got the thing wrong and
the bad thing happened i've now seen the
light
right you're because you're just kind of
saving your own butt because you're a
political outsider too right the
establishment doesn't love you either
um so the big tech guys could turn on
you too um
you know so how about you lead it bernie
how about you get a big one of them
their petitions going how about you get
all your socialist buddies and the
communists and everybody
on board and let's get donald trump back
on big tech
i'll sign that thing for you bernie
because i'm for free speech
and i think that would be the way to do
it i suspect bernie is not going to do
that
but he is just trying to you know save
face a little bit
at this point so as we wrap this story
up
either bernie is just what he is
and now he's just trying to cover it and
make sure he's okay
or he kind of gets it but as i've said a
lot lately i'm not really into people
who just talk i want you to do
so bernie sanders my hope is that you
will do
and let's get donald trump back on
social media because obviously you think
it's an important piece
of our american contract and free speech
i shall not hold
my breath uh all right so the next story
this is super interesting because
when i now say that the democrats and
and the lefties have become the racists
and the anti-racists
are the real racist you know some people
think i'm being sort of over the top
with that
or i'm being a little sarcastic or
something but but in essence
i really really am not the people who
purport
to be anti-racist are the ones obsessed
with racism they're the ones
who want quotas at schools and at
government
jobs and all of these things and even
our politicians now
the ideas of critical race theory the
ideas of social justice are such
viruses such viruses of the mind that
they are infecting
all of our politicians so yesterday
mazzy hirono who is a senator from
hawaii
she was on msnbc and she was asked about
whether
there's enough diversity in joe biden's
cabinet and how that would affect
her voting and listen to her very
carefully
one of your colleagues senator tammy
duckworth said today that she told the
white house she will vote against
all of president biden's nominees who
are still outstanding
until they rectify the the fact that
there is no aapi representation
in biden's cabinet do you stand with her
in that
time tammy's position
is that until she gets a commitment from
the white house that there will be more
diversity representation in the cabinet
and senior white house
advisory positions she will not vote to
confirm
anyone who does not represent diversity
so this is not about pitting
one diversity group against another i
think this is a
well articulated focused position and i
am prepared to join her in that do you
think the biden administration has been
adequately
receptive to your entreaties for more
diversity
obviously not otherwise tammy and i
wouldn't be taking our position
but we would like to encourage him to do
better
mazzy you were racist honey yeah
that's the thing mazzy is a racist and
so is senator duckworth because what
they are saying
is that they will oppose nominees unless
they are diverse enough so
in effect they will not allow
for a white nominee i mean if you were
to distill this thing all the way to its
essence
they will not allow for a white nominee
unless that person
is lgbtq now the hilarity of this
is that by throwing the q in there and
we've talked about why the t shouldn't
be
with the l's and the g's but by throwing
the q in there questioning
that means that a straight white man
who's married could get
all the way up to the nomination process
and then they're questioning him
and mazzy could say well you know you
know you're pretty qualified
uh and your resume checks out you seem
like a good decent guy but
you are straight and the guy could look
her straight in the eye and say well you
know
it's true i am straight i'm married to a
woman i'm a good
uh citizen and member of society i have
a couple kids i try to help the
community
but i do think brad pitt's kind of hot
and uh you know
maybe i'd be a little gay for brad pitt
not not full-blown gay but like i could
get like a little gay
over brad pitt and mazzy then would have
to by her own
idiotic her own idiotic
set of rules she would have to say oh i
guess this guy's in the lgbtq
community and that is how moronic these
people are
so what she and senator duckworth in
essence are saying
is we are racists we have decided
that diversity of immutable
characteristics is worth
more than hard work it is worth
more than history it is worth more than
all the skills that an individual person
might bring
you know there's that old lady of
justice you know that lady of justice
she sits outside all of our courts and
she's blindfolded you know that lady
you know why she's blindfolded because
she doesn't look at those things
however our democratic senators now do
well anyway this was yesterday on msnbc
and then of course what happens and this
is why they'll have to boot us all
from twitter one day is that a whole
bunch of people thousands and thousands
of people
started calling out mazzy and senator
duckworth
for being racist because it is racist
and it's systemic racism
because it's not just regular old racism
like oh i don't like a black guy that's
not good but
you know you're entitled to your opinion
you're entitled to associate with who
you like but they're actually the ones
bringing us systemic racism because what
she is saying is
me as a member of the senate i will
only vote for people based on race or in
this case she also
also adds sexuality that is injecting
racism into the system systemic racism
the thing that we don't have that they
say we have they're the ones importing
it
it's quite spectacular uh but because
a gajillion people yesterday called her
out on it called both of them out on it
on twitter uh then duckworth spokesman
senator tammy duckworth spokesman ben
gash
gamit garmiza issued this statement he
said
senator duckworth appreciates the biden
administration's
assurances that it will do much more to
elevate aapi
voices and perspectives at the highest
levels of government
including appointing an aapi senior
white house official to represent the
community
secure the confirmation of aapi
appointments
and advanced policy proposals that are
relevant and important to the community
accordingly she will not stand in the
way of president biden's qualified
nominees
which will include more aapi leaders
you know you're not going to believe
this guys but the aaip
or the aapi community they're doing
pretty well
in america maybe they're that not that
concerned about their representation in
the government because they succeed in
the real world they succeed in the
free marketplace they succeed in
business and education
and family and the things that matter
these people are just
really ridiculous pandering pinheads
and my god we must vote in better people
because
it's they're they're eroding all of the
good
things about america and by the way i
can't do a story on tammy duckworth and
not give a shout out to kevin duckworth
who is the center on the early 90s
blazers went to two nba finals was a
little overweight
uh but a decent jump shot for a center
and
actually i think he had a heart attack
about 10 years ago and died but was one
of my favorite ball players way back
when
all right let's move on to story three
project
veritas is suing the new york times
and you know anytime i see anyone going
after
the new york times it seems worthy of
talking about uh we've got a quote from
reclaim the net
project veritas is suing two new york
times writers for defamation in their
articles that were presented as factual
news
not opinions last year new york times
writers tiffany
sue and maggie astor made unverifiable
claims that a video by project veritas
about election irregularities in
minnesota
was deceptive in five articles now we've
got a quote from project veritas this is
the headline
of the video that was in question and i
actually saw this video when it came out
didn't get any major mainstream coverage
except to defame it
ilhan omar connected cash for ballots
voter fraud scheme corrupts elections
these here are all absentee ballots look
my car is full money is the king of
everything
okay and then they have a whole video
explaining what was going on there
let's go to a quote now from the new
york times piece
about that veritas video mr o'keefe and
project veritas have a long history of
releasing manipulated or selectively
edited footage purporting to show
illegal conduct
by democrats and liberal groups
it goes further on to say and this is
from tiffany sue that project veritas
magnified the reach of the deceptive
video
and finally a quote from the federalist
the judge ruled the lawsuit can go
forward finding that project veritas
showed sufficient evidence
that the new york times may have been
motivated by actual malice
and acted with reckless disregard when
it ran several
articles against the investigative
journalism
outfit and sorry one more quote on this
i'm a quote machine today this is from
judge
charles wood new york state supreme
court if a writer interjects an opinion
in a news article
and will seek to claim legal protections
as opinion
it stands to reason that the writer
should have an obligation to alert the
reader
including a court that may need to
determine whether it's
a factor opinion whether it is
fact or opinion oh sorry whether it is
fact or opinion not factor opinion
that is the opinion okay so i know i
went a little heavy
on the quotes there but you really need
to understand the story because it's
super interesting so project
veritas runs this story on ilhan omar
and
ballot harvesting which they stand by
the new york times then reports on it
but injects opinion in what they claim
is an objective article right and that
then you're conflating opinion and fact
now of course the new york times does
this with virtually everything the new
york times is not a newspaper
excuse me the new york times is
basically a place of propaganda i would
say at this point
um they've ran stories saying that i
lead people to the alt
right with a picture of my face remember
that one that was a good one
jordan peterson was included in that and
ben shapiro and uh
phil defranco and noble prize winning
economist milton friedman you know all
really scary people that lead people to
the alt-right and in the very premise of
the article they follow this youtuber as
he
goes down the the you know goes down the
well
into becoming far right and all right
but then you're not going to believe
this he gets saved by lefty youtube
thus disproving the very point of the
article because the point of the article
is that youtube can lead people to the
far right but this kid is saved by
youtube
and becomes a good lefty but in the eyes
of the new york times that's good
so now it the new the youtube algorithms
basically
are good things anyway i don't want to
make this about me but the point is the
new york times is trash i think we all
know it's trash
and i hope that project veritas wins uh
i saw that
uh james o'keefe actually posted a poll
on twitter
whether he should just settle with the
new york times because most likely
they'll just offer him cash to stay out
of court or go for it
and of course everybody's saying go for
it but i hope he bangs them up
i really hope he bangs them up the only
thing that is going to stop the
institutional creep
and destruction of all of our norms is
suing these people sue
the fake news new york times sue the
colleges that discriminate against
asian people sue the businesses who do
all these things and
and and sue the politicians who decide
to lock us down and everything else
sadly that's all we've been left with um
and that's that's probably the way we
got to go so good luck to james o'keefe
and the folks at project veritas all
right guys one more um
you know i obviously talk a lot about
california here on the show
and i am still in california california
right now is still
closed for indoor dining which makes
absolutely
no sense zero sense it's completely
insane
what percentage are we at outdoors do
you know what percentage we're at
something
we're at uh 25 outdoor
it's beautiful out it's 80 and sunny
every day in california none of it makes
any sense anymore
we're opening disneyland in a few weeks
at 25 capacity but we can't eat indoor
now it's like
you can't do you know and then oh the
other one i covered this last week
when you're on a roller coaster at
disney or adventureland or whatever it
might be
you can't yell what are they going to do
are they going to literally have snipers
and there's going to be kids like
like we're just going to take kids out
you know like that for health
for a safe and secure society
anyway i'm not thrilled with california
i've been to florida a couple times
it's free it's spectacular it's sunny
it's wonderful the people are happy
all of that good stuff they smile it's
just great well uh clay travis
over at outkick ran a really interesting
story comparing some actual numbers and
i know this is scary for some people but
we gonna do it anyway uh the california
unemployment rate
is 9.3 percent and the covet death rate
per a million residents is 1413.
florida has an unemployment rate of 5.1
percent
and a covid death rate per a million
residents
at 1 503. now let's compare this to
florida
florida's covid death rate is a bit
higher than california's we'll get to
that in a second
but when you adjust for the average age
of population
florida which has a much larger elderly
population than california
has actually outperformed california
when it comes to dealing
with covid deaths in the state florida
without
shutting schools or the economy has
managed to vastly outperform california
in objective covid virus metrics
florida should be a model for every
state's covid
response so what uh what clay is
actually talking about there
is that the rate in florida it is a tiny
bit more
it's negligible to the point it's not
even worth talking about basically
but the unemployment rate is basically
half of what california is
they kept people working they let them
leave their homes as i said
when i went there people were out and
about people were smiling
florida a lot of old people and they
were making choices
for themselves i walked the beach with
old people
and they didn't run from each other they
didn't even shuffle from each other they
talked to each other i was actually
hanging out with a group of about
20 older people we they like white wine
i'm not a white wine guy i was doing a
little margarita situation but i met
this
elderly group of people and we were all
hanging out and they made decisions for
themselves and it was just fine and
their economy
was not destroyed so ron desantis
save me come to california and save me
would you
or am i i guess i'm gonna have to go to
you that's how it works in this country
you've got your foot vote dave
and you're allowed to leave at least for
now if the state you live in isn't in
line with your beliefs
well at least we got to recall gavin
newsom huh that's uh that's still going
ahead by the way which
are you seeing any coverage of it on
mainstream news
anything anywhere there's literally
nothing anywhere
on mainstream news over two million
people signed a recall to take out the
governor of the largest state in the
union
and it's completely being ignored
although
as the man we started with earlier
before earlier
today bernie sanders says it's a vast
right-wing conspiracy
to take out david
bernie bernie bernie guys part two of my
interview with lawrence
fox who is now the leader of the reclaim
party in the uk and
running for governor of london he was
just an actor a year ago
he was just an actor who stepped in it
by saying some truth on a british tv
show
got attacked by the mob they cancelled
him and he decided to fight that's what
it's all about because if you fight back
they will not take you out so part two
of my interview with lawrence is on
youtube right now the full episode is up
absolutely
ad free at reubenreport.locals.com
and we are doing a friday panel on
education it will all be about
education during this crazy time can we
get kids back to schools what's going on
with these bananas
teachers unions especially in california
and new york
the problems of purely online education
and and a bunch more on that so i'm
looking forward to sharing that with you
guys
all right have a great day everybody and
we will do it again
tomorrow
you